doch nur weil sie die wertvollen prima
friedhelm macht weiter da hinten letztes
in der wüste ich habe aber keine axt
schaufel ich wäre jetzt einfach mal ein
paar sachen die ich aus der höhle hatte
braten und dann schauen die trommel max
ist schon geil diese branche sagt es
genauso wieder als durch ja ich hab
diesen bisschen besser bei uns ist ja
auch besser die rüstung halseisen so
also was sollte ich machen ich muss
überlegen überlegen so voll an
so wird es auch niemandem 1000 mal reist
doch immer wieder doch er hat es jetzt
muss er ganz ganz viele öfen machen wir
jetzt viele verschiedene ärzte hat auf
der ersten tour ist richtig und normal
ich hab so was von cras viele ärzte ihr
euch das mal rein bitte freunde bitte
freundet sich das rein bitte bitte
freuen ich habe ihr gesagt ja häufig
mache ich habe leider schon gegen weg
darunter geht und habe noch ein weg nach
unten gemacht wird ich wusste sagt so
blöd um gespielt und gespielt der spd
hatte ich stand überhaupt meinte oder
ich gar nicht verstanden was war jetzt
nicht wirklich doch die party ab apatit
vielleicht kann man das damit ja machen
guten appetit sie entstammen
nein es ist aber egal wo du bist was du
bin ich denn nicht mal kurz runter ich
möchte immer das soll zeigen ob es extra
zu dir da hochrum dieses dir dieses
ewige holzzuber nach ganz oben ganz gar
nicht erst einmal zuschauen war
wie das bei dir da um so aussieht aber
ganz große frage heute samstag oder
heute samstag ja okay da verdenken dass
sonntag während ich morgen wenn meine
erste arbeitsprobe seite abgeben muss
ich komme dabei so durcheinander ich bin
so viel rumreisen einfach ich bin so
happy
nein bisher soviel sag mal hast kommt
man das holz anbieten
es ist nämlich gar nicht an mich
ausgeschieden
dann kommt zu mir recht seeland nichts
runter dir das holz wir hätten du musst
schon hoch bringen bringt mir nichts
wenn ich die zur unterkommen muss in die
welt bringt jetzt nichts soll
minenschacht ihr durch man da stößt man
sich jedes mal den kopf dass er schritte
wo ist das holz denn wo ist das denn für
richtig wie stein- oder so ist oder
kisten ist so ist so verfährt man wird
erst für diesen reiz es sieht richtig
scheiße aus einfach nur das heute aber
welchen bauch ist aus den schnell kannst
du das leben im haus klemme was von
welchem haus bauen ist das denn von
diesem aktien stammen ich bin ganz weit
gereist da einmal damit soll katzen da
savanne getroffen einmal wieder raus
einfach stocker doch mein wachturm ist
erbaut
ja bei mir noch nicht so viel
hier ist immer noch seine katze
entstammt und zurück so jetzt wollte ich
mir mal gucken ob ich aus dem apatit
dann nehme ich da habe ich dann doch
apatit vielleicht mit einer spitzhacke
machen kann ist auf jeden verständlich
weil wenig appetit
ich habe nicht so viel appetit heute ich
glaub ich erst echt nix machen und
aufgefallen du kannst immer rezept
angucken ach ja stimmt ich über den
rezepten dauern
was eine blaue gästen etwas nicht
wiederholt sich alles mal auf aber die
komischen avancen des network jackett
table was war ich hier für hässliche
gebäude das ist hässlich was ich für
bauer ist so kann ich wieder ganz
schnell ein kriegen
ich will die dings finden
die werkzeuge manchmal wenn ich das
jetzt so bauer dann ist es schön ist das
noble brinsa vier schaufel flexit
gekommen dass denn dafür braucht man
dafür braucht man google dafür braucht
man prominenter 4
axis nicht kaputtmacht
so viel satire habe ich das kind schon
überhaupt muss man den kisten gucken
gibt auch verschiedene flüssigkeiten
ganz ganz viele tränke dafür braucht man
wie macht man sich den traum jedes mal
aufgepasst noch passt wie macht man sich
eine tommy m
ja ich weiß auch nicht aufgepasst jetzt
aber aufgepasst
ja muss ich schauen was sind es sich aus
dieser bohrer damen trio kann ich
irgendwie suchen da wo man kann ja sogar
suche nach kobe um
ich weiß nicht was hier bei
speicherchips top schöner absorbieren
kann man einfach nur finden
das kann sich auch ganze rüstung machen
ja das finde ich ja geil so lila sound
nervt die uns von craft wahrscheinlich
von dieser mod signale
kraft die in dieser kiste da liegen dass
meine jetzt männer rein gelegt hast was
befestigt was brauche ich fertige
gebilde das video was er in dem video
antworten ist das per hässlich baut auch
man ich wollte was schönes bauen und
jetzt alle fest ich bin enttäuscht von
meiner hütte hier bin ich von dir bin
richtig enttäuscht war ich hab den drei
schon hier muss ich die bauen
doch jetzt ein fenster ein zimmer das
nicht dreier deckenhöhe erst 34 sind 73
ich muss mal acht meine axis kaputt ich
glaube die leute die mir zu gucken
denken sie mal was bist du für den sport
die liste für den sport
ich glaube das haus das ich glaube dass
burkhard ich werd wahnsinnig ich wollte
schon das haus bauen aber ich bin
überfordert
unsterbliche beim hausbau echt stock
reisen zusammen ergibt das ein
sollte wirklich mal was essen später tot
und ich habe so viel leveln effekte auf
das ich dir mit verbauen kann wie gegen
den champion table zweiten mal an den
svm group and schade finde ich gar nicht
ins getümmel fährt sauber und suche ich
ihnen jetzt mal wo ich doch da war schon
schade da ist sauber tisch einfach nur
zwei diamanten vier obsidian und einem
buch das heißt wir brauchen diamanten um
obsidian abzubauen das heißt wir haben
schon recht jemanden insgesamt fünf
diamanten in den job mit table zu kommen
das heißt ich mache meine höhle
ich weiß auch nicht warum macht ihr seid
ja aber ich bin richtig richtig richtig
den nerv im haus verweist sich im krieg
er warte ich bloß ein bisschen zu ende
ich hatte irgendwie so eine gewisse
vorstellung und hab ich gemerkt das volk
habe und der geiler sieg im hintergrund
nicht war keine musik mit meinen eltern
gehen pullover machen die partie also
die haben auf jeden fall musikern
richtig rum strahlkraft als keine
richtige party ja was schreibt man ganz
kurz meiner mutter ist live dabei wenn
ich mir hier eine sms schreibe so
whatsapp verbinden kann ich schon mal
dabei war ein kompletter seiner mutter
eine sms schreibt geheim
natürlich fragt man sagt ihr seid noch
wach halte ich hier mein vater sind
weniger zeit bilder von seiner komischen
bach als app da kann man so ein foto von
sich einfinden wird man so in 50 jahren
dargestellt das finde ich total witzig
witzig bei mir eben noch rüstung und
dann bin ich bereit für die expedition
okay ich weiß ja
online chf erreichte gold rüsten gründen
am anfang seinen goldenen kopf haben
immer kurz light orion oder würstchen
steak das heißt sparen die ganze zeit
mox egal ob das recht voll cool töten
jetzt leute relativ ich würd sagen wir
können einfach draußen rumlaufen und
jetzt ganz viele obwohl wir brauchen ja
ich brauche jemanden ich hab ja ich bin
richtig ausgerüstet ich habe alle meine
werkzeuge alles dabei jetzt geht es los
ich habe noch nie es dabei nicht so viel
hast du ganz viel gemüse ich hab doch
jetzt wie gesagt fleisch für dich ich
habe fast gar nichts das ist es
silberbach hier drin die ich auf jeden
fall noch ja ich werde bald meine ganzen
tipps kiste hier sortieren
auch die wenig immer die kommentare
schreiben ja private stücke habe ich auf
jeden fall erstmal mit schwerter auf
spitzhacken könnte ich genau machen
jetzt gerade richtig geile idee gekommen
soll erstmal schlafen gehen ja ich hab
eben zu wenig darüber
ich glaub der regel weg ist eine richtig
geile idee allein mit einem alten haus
oder kein bett mehr drin da ist kein es
kaum mehr kombinieren zu weit
zurückliegen von da aus geht los in
richtung es ist eine richtig geile idee
gekommen nämlich wir können ja
irgendwann im laufe des tages ihren
arena bauen und dann irgendwann richtige
pvp kämpfe gegen halle austragen und
also so kämpfe um irgendwelche wichtigen
nochmal und nochmal bitte sagen ich hab
dann auf die erst mal meine mutter
geachtet
sichtlich überrascht also ich hab gesagt
wir könnten ja ich hab dich geschlagen
so haben wir in monsters nebenbei
workshops sind die monster bitte wo ist
schnell installiert weg schnell schlecht
im bett macht die täter die zu sowas
sollte zu sagen hatte ich kann ich ins
bett gehe jetzt nicht gerettet sein
also ich glaub ich mal mein sound ist
langsam ein ingame sound weil der ist
nämlich ein bisschen sehr laut macht er
zu 15 prozent unter dem namen weil das
der regel extrem es regnet immer noch
okay mir hört jetzt auf ok